اكدت حركه حماس موقفها الرافض لاي مفاوضات
لتبادل الاسرى ما لم يتوقف العدوان نهائيا
وقالت في بيان انها ابلغت الوسطاء بذلك
وكان القيادي في حركه حماس اسامه حمدان قد
قال انه لا تبادل للاسرى قبل وقف كامل
للعدوان وقبول شروط المقاومه واضاف ان
45% من الشهداء الذين ارتقوا بجنوب غزه هم
من النازحين ما يكذب ادعاءات الاحتلال
وجود مناطق امنه واوضح ان جيش الاحتلال
ارتكب نحو 1700 مجزره في غزه خلال
يوما اقول لعائلات الاسرى من جنود
الاحتلال
والمحتجزين ساعتكم هذه قد تعد الى ما لا
نهايه ومع مغامرات نتنياهو وحكومته ثلاثيه
الرؤوس قد لا يعودون احياء ابدا ان
الروايه التي اوردها الاعلام الصهيوني حول
مقتل المحتجزين الثلاثه تدلل على ان جيش
الاحتلال ينتقل في غزه من فشل الى فشل فشل
استراتيجي واخر تكتيكي وان عقيدته
القتاليه النازيه تجعله يغرق اكثر فاكثر
في مستنقع الفشل الذي يصنعه في غزه ان
اراد هذا العدو ان يستعيد جنوده الاسرى
لدى المقاومه احياء فان ذلك لن يتم ولن
يتحقق الا بعد توقف كامل للعدوان ثم عبر
صفقه تفاوض وفق شروط
المقاومه